[Music]
today on drew take a deep dive into the
best of season one i'm so in awe that
we're all still so close we've
experienced everything together and we
gear up for our star-studded two-week
premiere event
in my original hometown of hollywood
i grew up here in los angeles i love it
here it all starts now
please welcome drew barrymore
hi everyone the countdown is on for
season two premiere of the drew
barrymore show it's less than a week
away and the first thing we're gonna do
is show our undying appreciation
for all of our home towns i'm going to
start in my hometown of los angeles but
before we do that let's take a look back
at how we got here
these are our favorite moments from
season one and we curated them just for
you
we kicked off the season premiere
with two women that i just
well
they're my nearest and dearest that
first guest is a really important thing
in the talk show world and i actually
said
could i have my friends on
you might happen to know who they are
ironically
it's uh cameron diaz and lucy liu my
fellow charlie's angels take a look
we all made charlie's angels we made it
and we're making this show
and so when we sat around and thought
about who is this you know first guest
nothing felt right nothing was there and
all of a sudden in like a divine
intervention
i was like
cameron and lucy and everything fell
into place
massive congratulations this is really
major for you i um
listen you know everybody says who's
gonna be your first guest it's like i
mean we've been through
everything together you know well
everything everything
literally everything
i
haven't been i haven't got i haven't had
a wedding that you guys haven't been at
i've been to all your weddings
to all of them
like when our babies are born we
hang out and we do the birthday party
thing i can't believe we're all moms now
that's when i got really emotional first
i sent
cameron a video and i'm saying hey
listen i got at like i want to ask you
something will you come on the show um
which
i mean
i've never done this in my life because
i'm so comfortable i mean we have lived
together all over the world so of course
to save time i sent her a video while
i'm getting dressed and
you don't see anything i'm not that dumb
but i'm getting out of the shower and
i'm like ringing out of my towel and i
don't hear back from her for like two
days and i'm like this is weird
did i what is going on so i text her and
i'm like i don't care about the question
are you okay i don't hear again for two
days i'm freaking out so i call her and
i'm like what is going on i'm worried is
everything okay she's like i don't know
what you're talking about i'm like the
video
you didn't get my video
turns out
a young boy
watched the video
lucky him
oh no
oh no by the way it's like seven minutes
long oh my god
there it
epic i mean this is some material
secrets
material
for like honestly he can use this is
going to last him three or four years
i mean i you know i'm really like
hamming it up because it's you know
because it's you yeah that was good i
was like send me that video immediately
i need to know
what is in that video and the whole
while i'm just like
cracking up because you need to send me
this video as well or do it through
someone else because i didn't get your
other video either so then someone's
like did you get her videos like no
no i'm something's wrong with my phone
so i sent lucy this video crying
inviting her on the show saying in her
bathroom crying i am in my bag she was
dressed
i was fully clothed this time i didn't
take the risk and she didn't get the
video either
come on
i know i know you uh
the thing that i love about our
friendship
is that we have been there in all the
big and important moments we've also
been there in the small moments and the
casual moments and the reason we are
such good friends is because it's real
and we go through real stuff with each
other it's not a hollywood fairy tale
it's
life is not there's no aspect of life
that's an actual hollywood fairy tale
that's why it's a hollywood fairy tale
because it doesn't exist you want it's
aspirational it's hopeful but life is
constantly full of twists and turns and
all of those things that
happen over a lifetime because truly it
is now a lifetime i mean 20 years is
a long time y'all like i'm i'm two years
away from 50.
you know that's nearly half my life we
have charlie's angels as our
sort of backdrop that brought us
together but then we get to fill in all
of
life together in real moments which i
just so appreciate so true it's so well
said honey i know because it's like it's
our touch point you know yeah but then
we have that foundation and then we've
obviously grown and learned and changed
and i mean i know that 20 years has gone
by but i feel like it was yesterday i
feel just as fresh and as young and as
you know creatively uh i don't know
excited as i was when i started here's
the thing about charlie's angels
is that it's about
girls who can do
all of these things
and love each other and don't have
competition and support each other and
laugh and want to talk about
love and life so much that they actually
start to talk about love and life while
they're fighting because women are so
like that it all intersects and that is
why i asked you guys here today is
because if you're going to do something
big
you want to do it with your girlfriends
that's right
and
and i and i love being together although
are we really together are we all
together in this room
are we i feel like we're connected in
some way but maybe
for anyone watching
can you guess which one of us isn't
really here
welcome
you gotta try this it's so incredible
the ether little particles going out
into space and coming back and remasting
into this beautiful space
you guys it's crazy you should try it
tingles
[Laughter]
all right we're not done yet with those
ladies more with cameron and lucy up
next
[Music]
we're back to bring you more
[Music]
the new season of drew premieres
september 13th
welcome back we just showed our premier
interview
with my nearest and dearest cameron diaz
and lucy liu
later in that episode the three of us
dove into our ongoing roles
as moms take a look
so we grew
and we grew up
and now
we are moms do you think you're a
different person now lucy than you were
then like aside from us knowing each
other and our friendship just you as a
human
i think in my 20s i felt very
bulletproof
and very
you know
i don't want to say it was risk-taking
because it was beyond that it was like i
didn't really care if i lived or died
you know i just didn't and i lost my
father a few years ago and
i didn't really recognize the levels
that we have in our lives and
you know like he was a place
in my
in my life that was always sort of a
kind of a a roof
you know and so suddenly you feel like
the the roof has been torn off
and then you sort of recognize oh you
know i am now the roof
you know and i happen to have a child so
i guess i'm the roof to that child so
now i really have to understand that i
shelter him and i have to show i'm i
have a responsibility and it's it's a
very powerful thing it's also terrifying
if i think about it i think my heart was
smaller back then because it was sort of
more inclined to what i wanted to do but
now it's sort of like what do we want to
do and it feels it feels good because i
feel like a fuller person
like life seems a much more you know
kind of
colorful and wild because there's so
many more opportunities as a mom
to kind of like discover and you know
there's so much more curiosity with kids
and it's sort of it's mind-blowing and
it's actually more terrifying in a way
you know because you're also responsible
for this little person highest stakes so
it's like oh my god i thought i was on a
riot you know a ride back then a wild
ride but actually it's now that it's
even more intense well you nailed it
because you're just dealing with your
own mortality and all of the sudden when
you have a kid
i don't care if it sounds codependent my
kids are more meaningful to me than my
own life i think there's something that
in our dna that gets triggered you know
like that just clicks on
um
when you're you become a parent you have
to to make sure that they they survive
they have to they go on you
we will die
i'm sorry to get like morbid and this is
those times when drew goes
really you're going to die do we have to
talk about that
for your first show it's all about
mortality i know i know i'm ready to
talk
like wait a minute i feel like i'm no
longer a young idiot who thinks i am
immortal which i'm glad to know i'm not
i wasn't the only one i mean i hurled
myself around i abused this carcass to
no end
and i just thought true i was gonna die
young so who cares live now and go for
it and now yeah i mean 2020 will make
you think about your mortality children
will make you think about mario
mortality you know my 20s it was just
sort of like here we go yeah all right
jump on that
gotcha oh is that a wild horse oh cool
yeah no i know how to hold on for my
life let's go you know there's such a
liberation in that too though you know
and yeah so glad i did it all when i
thought about
trying to accomplish something big
in my life at another point you two were
the people i did it with and so of
course what a natural fit
that you're the two people that came
into my head in my heart when i thought
how would i like
to honor this endeavor
i see myself with you guys i feel like
it's exactly what the world needs they
need your light they need your
joyousness they need your perspective
what
one of the things that i have always
been in total awe of
and you is your ability to like take in
all the information how quick you are to
not just like what's in front of you but
like the nuances and the the sort of the
humanity and intellect you can you read
more books than any person i know you uh
you listen to more music you um
look at more art you bring you watch
more
television and film you're actually
taking in all the information and you're
synthesizing it and you're bringing it
into this really unique perspective that
is all about how it like connects all of
us together even if it doesn't feel like
it has anything to do with one another
and you bring it to the world in this
joyous beautiful
like buoyant light that is you
and you give it's a gift it's like a
truly a gift that you give the world and
you're gonna make the world a happier
better place by giving us that gift you
have a big soul and a big heart
and doing this show is really special
and wonderful because you have something
to share and you have gone through tough
times in your life you've had issues
with your family you've had issues with
you know
like marriages divorces you have
something to share and i don't know that
i can say that about a lot of things
i've never been married i've never been
doors i haven't done a lot of things
that you have so to me the experience
that you have and that you have to share
is exciting and i think that you should
feel free to do that because that's who
you are you're very open generous person
i asked you guys here so i could honor
you today
that's what this was about for me yeah
but you can't honor us without us
honoring you that this is the symbiotic
relationship and you have to be able to
give and take and understand that a lot
of times when i give up like a friend a
compliment they can't take it you know
and like it's we have it's time for us
to receive
in this case to say i love those women
well it's just not enough
and um i'm so in awe of the fact that
we're all still so close and
get to talk about being parents we've
experienced everything together
my cameron i call her auntie poopoo is
gonna come back for season two we're
gonna do a whole hour together it's
gonna be so
fun
stay tuned to find out when that is in
the season premiere week
[Music]
[Music]
we're back to bring you more
[Music]
the new season of drew premiere
september 13th
here's a little weekday motivation from
someone who inspires us
hey drew it's your friend zoe long time
when i first discovered that stunts was
something that people got paid to do and
made a career out of i became instantly
obsessed my dad at the time was working
at an emergency clinic as a doctor and a
guy came in with a concussion
and turned out to be a stunt man and my
dad speaks volumes about who my father
is came home with the phone number
because he knew that i wanted to be a
stunt woman and i immediately was like
what do you talk about i can't call that
person just felt so uncomfortable and
gross and
my dad made a statement that i just it
stopped me in my tracks because it was
literally irrefutable you could make
that phone call today or you cannot and
if you don't make the phone call you'll
wake up tomorrow and it'll be a normal
wednesday and you'll be the same zoe you
are when you went to sleep and your life
will be the same life you've got now and
that's all great
um or you could make the phone call and
you might wake up tomorrow get me
emotional
you might wake up tomorrow as some woman
it stopped me in my tracks in a way that
i was like oh
well then i just need to make the phone
call because what's the risk you know
and uh
that literally was the beginning of
a career where i have been a stunt woman
and then an actor and since producer and
i'm now getting into directing and it's
all because of that sense of don't say
no to something because
of fear
now that was inspiring
[Music]
welcome back as we gear up for season
two of the drew barrymore show it's in
less than a week and we're looking back
at some of our favorite moments from
season one and hands down one of my
favorite moments was when we introduced
our cookbook club to the world and to
help me do that we had the wonderful
chef
and all-around incredible human being
jose andreas take a look
what are you teaching me today
eggs with chickpeas and tomato sauce
you do it in five minutes
i mean that's revelatory because that's
such a deterrent because when they say
prep time 20 minutes cook time 60
minutes
it's not realistic for a lot of people's
lives
so listen we have the pan we have the
oil and you have garlic i have garlic
right here put the garlic on there on
the pan
and now talk to your garlic tell hey
darling how are you how are you doing
baby hey baby how's it going my kid's
grandfather ari that's what he always
says hey baby the garlic is speaking
back to you
and the garlic is telling you
oh i'm so happy i'm cooking with raw i'm
jose
it's amazing i love garlic the more the
better
okay so in this moment we put the
chickpeas now roger that this is
actually great to buy
a can of chickpeas which are delicious
and usually they have a very good price
on the supermarket i was gonna say i
think they're a very uh healthy thing
for people and you have a vegetable book
and for vegetarians they're a really
satisfying like protein substitute i
love them so you take a look at the
chickpeas they're so happy because they
love to be with the garlic people don't
know this but chickpeas and garlic they
are very friendly okay you have to lift
up the temperature put higher
temperature bro oh jose i'm so excited
to tell you that i just did that that
means we're telepathically linked now
i'm in
so in this moment this is very important
i will add a little bit more foil to
your pan i love olive oil um by the way
check this olive oil out okay hang on
beauty shot there we go i love your
olive oil thank you so much for sending
it to us
let's say you have fresh tomatoes you
can get a peeled fresh tomato and cut it
in cubes or
you have canned tomatoes
and also works very well or
you have
any pasta tomato sauce that is already
made
everything works
just make sure that you do whatever you
have at home is what you use i think
that makes people less stressed in the
kitchen thank you
drew recipes should be like life itself
when you don't have some of the
ingredients
just move on change the recipe in your
dishes or in your life and you'll always
be successful that's a very important
lesson in cooking and in life
jose look i'm sizzling baby
so now
i have a can of a spanish pimenton yes
what we call paprika if you have it if
you don't have paprika called chili
flakes if you don't have put
cumin if you don't put whatever spice
you have in your kitchen make the recipe
your own
a paprika i love you so
and now i'm putting the tomato in
because if tomato is already cooked
it's going to be easy i mean i cannot
prove that i am actually cooking with
you
i mean when i told my daughters they
were like come on daddy don't make fun
of us
i'm cooking with her jose how old are
your daughters
i have three uh carlota she's 21.
ines she's 19th and lufia she's 16.
so listen this is very important now
there's tomato sauce the chickpea
everything is cooked and i am putting
inside
four of my pets
in this moment you put some salt on the
eggs
and ladies and gentlemen
you cover the pot
and now you can open a glass of wine
you can open yourself a beer you can
drink a sherry
so
why i'm doing this one pod drew because
very often many recipes they require
three or four or five pops
you can make everything with one pot no
cleaning this is great i love one pot i
think
it really helps people feel like they
can manage so one pot for me is you know
a great way to cook that makes that
keeps me calm
this pandemic i've been cooking a lot
with my daughters and we did some
cooking
on social media and quite frankly we
were doing it because it was fun because
we were spending so many hours and we
began sharing it with people
and
was one of the best moments of my life
to be cooking with my three daughters
already
man i remember them first time i had
them in my arms and i was crying it was
after they came up into the wall and now
21 years later i realized through this
pandemic that there are these three
grown-up girls and to me cooking with my
daughters has been the happiest moment
of my life
look at that look at that beauty shot
and now i'm gonna try it
okay yeah
oh yeah
oh god that's good
the great thing about this dish
is that you can make it your own in so
many ways you can cook it every time and
every time be a different recipe you can
put some mozzarella you can put some
manchego cheese oh
topping it with cheese would like kick
kick it up a whole other level you're
right and don't be afraid of trying new
things always just take risk they will
always pay off
i love jose's garlic tip i've actually
been using it and it is foolproof and
when it comes to the kitchen i will take
anything foolproof and when it comes to
jose i will follow him wherever he goes
he actually just got a grant of a
hundred million dollars for his world
central kitchen to keep on taking care
of everyone the way
only he can do so for more memorable
moments from season one they're coming
up next stay tuned
welcome back something i find very
authentic about our show is we try to
cover the spectrum
we laugh
we talk about pop culture we cook clean
and just like in life we also cry we get
mad and we like to deal with the tough
stuff
last season i was honored to get the
opportunity to sit down with dylan
farrow
at the time she was the subject of the
documentary allen versus pharaoh about
the alleged abuse that she endured as a
child and she
was ready to open up and talk about her
story i'm very glad that she did it with
me take a look
i want to say
first out of the gate
i would like to explain myself
because this is not about me but i
wanted to sort of have this type of
candor
i worked with woody allen i did a film
with him in 1996 called everyone says i
love you
and um
there was no higher career calling card
than to work with woody allen
and
then i had children
and
it changed me
because i realized
that i was one of the people who was
basically gaslit
into
not looking
at
a narrative beyond what i was being told
and i see what's happening in the
industry now yeah
and that is because of you making that
brave choice
so thank you
for that
thank you oh my goodness hearing what
you just said like i mean i i'm trying
not to cry right now
um
but like
it it it just just
so meaningful because it's easy for me
to say like of course you shouldn't work
with him you know he's a jerk he's a
monster but
i just find it incredibly
brave and incredibly
generous
that
that you would say to me that um
that my story and what what i what i
went through
was important
enough to you to to reconsider that
absolutely
and
how hard was it
for you to engage in this documentary
which i really want to make a caveat
about that your family did not produce
no no they came to us i think that's
very important for people to understand
your family did not produce this
documentary we participated and
apparently everyone was asked to
participate yeah no they they
they went to everyone um and
and and that was important you know
even just to me to know that like that
there was
a level of journalistic integrity at
work here so did your family get
together and say these people are
different they're taking a tone they're
using a diligence there there's a
thoroughness here that feels safer in
order to come out and make this brave
decision
um
i was actually the one who
initially
told
my mom and told ronan you know like hey
you know i sat down with with these
people and i really think that they are
on the up and up so then when my mom
agreed to be interviewed i was
really really shocked and when ronan
agreed i was even more shocked and then
fletcher agreed and i was i mean i was
picking my job off the floor
and you know gradually more and more of
my siblings signed on and a few of them
didn't and i've spoken to them about
that too and i i respect that decision
as well
um
but i mean in terms of like
a family meeting
not really but um
but there was there was communication
and interestingly the the documentary
has led to
greater
communication between us as a result i
think which is interesting
may i ask why you were surprised that
they signed on i think
mostly because
we wouldn't talk about it to each other
so talking about it
publicly
[Music]
it was just it just seemed
absolutely
incomprehensible
how did your mom feel watching
the documentary
i mean it was tough because i would have
loved to have been able to watch the
series with her
and at the time that just
wasn't possible we were we were in
separate quarantine pods unfortunately
so
i really sort of
heard everything from her after the fact
you know it was just a very strange
pathway that we
navigated
separately and together
but i think it it definitely
changed a lot about how we
how me and my mom
relate to each other and interact with
each other and
i think there's a very
renewed
level of just respect
just woman to woman
i mean
sometimes when i think back
on memories of my life there has like a
gauze a patina a sort of surrealist
reverie
um
i know
mentally that time has gone by
but
i also can feel like i can be back there
in a moment's notice like that
um even if it does feel almost watching
a home movie
and then when you
were
watching the home movie of you
what did you think and feel and remember
it was a really
bizarre psychological experience for me
honestly because
i
had the video in my house
um
i gave it to my husband and i just said
put it into sort of like the darkest
corner that you can find just know where
it is
and that moment of just in case happened
when
i was talking to amy and she asked if
she could
see slash use the video in the series
and my first reaction was like
absolutely not like no i draw the line
here this is
too much it is too personal i don't want
to see the video i don't want anybody
else to see this video
and
amy i don't know how she talked me into
it she managed
to get the video taken i i had my
husband
bring it out of that dark corner of
wherever he stashed it in the closet
and
uh we watched it
sitting in my house and i just suddenly
burst into tears
and it just it hit me everything from
the tape just
i mean
it punched me right in the face and i
was just sobbing uncontrollably
for like a couple of days on and off
about what i saw and just sort of
trying to
mentally
reconcile
the fact that
that little girl on the tape
was me
and she was talking about something that
happened
to me and
it was
overwhelming
it's very
difficult sometimes
to know that
that part of me
is
such
a dark painful
place i mean because when i look at my
life now i have a wonderful husband i
have a wonderful daughter i have a
wonderful life and
i'm really excited about you know my
career writing and you know
taking my daughter to kindergarten next
year and all the all the wonderful
things that surround me
and yet there is this
impenetrable darkness
deep deep inside
that
i mean i'm gonna be honest i just i
still don't know what to do with wow
how do you deal with any fears that crop
up as a parent because i have mine from
my own history or my own stories or
things that are big triggers to me
i mean i i think about that a lot
because
i do have things that trigger me in my
daily life things that you know
are probably just like completely stupid
for other people that just send me
down the spiral and i'm actually kind of
proud of myself that i've gotten to the
point where i can
see a trigger or experience some sort of
trigger
i freeze and all that
you know fun stuff happens the the
emotions the
the recall the sensations
and
i can
process it
and
sometimes it means wading through some
of the negativity
how do you tell people
to handle their triggers if you see
an image
i mean
i mean this happened to me
like last week maybe the week before i
was just you know scrolling through my
uh news feed and an article pops up that
you know who and his his wife went to a
restaurant
and i was just
tailspin completely
i was just like i can't handle this i
don't want to see this like why are they
going to restaurants anyway like
i was
really very heavily triggered and i was
not okay and
it took
a couple days
of me just sort of like
trying to like massage myself back into
a normal space can i ask
do you
you know if people
looking in who maybe have not
experienced anything like this is it the
layers the repetition the many years you
watched the documentary and
it's it's it's really i mean the
unfairness of it it's frustrating and
then it makes me feel
hopeless like
like what was the point of it and then
it's reminding myself
of
facts that i know
things that i can
tether to
the documentary did accomplish something
i mean i think rain reported that people
were calling them at an increased rate
of like about 20 percent during
the documentary which means that
survivors are out there
connecting with my story and and healing
from it
it's bittersweet
thinking you know like
this story
is something that connects
a lot of survivors who are hurting
and
okay what more can we do for them like
how how can we make
this this world a space that women feel
empowered
or
feel at least less
terrified
that is so well said thank you
it really is what a perfect amazing
answer to that question
it's tough because like i wish that i
could say like here is
here is like you know a
10-step plan to you know completely
feeling healed and fulfilled in your
life if you follow these steps you know
you're you're going to be just fine
i wish i had that what works for me
might not work for
somebody else
so i think the best
the best advice that i offer is just
be true to yourself and
and and and and the truth that you have
lived
i think that's
really good advice i really do
i couldn't be more impressed by how
dylan has handled herself her history
and even the criticism aimed at her for
decades her resilience is a complete
inspiration
we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome back it's time for drew's news a
very special very precocious truce news
because in season one we introduced you
to our adorable seven-year-old kid
reporter emmy eaton
take a look
we love to look forward to the next
generation of newsers and in that spirit
we have a very special guest she is a
budding young journalist from idaho
falls who's becoming an internet
sensation
for her interviews she's interviewed her
mom her dad her neighbors keith morrison
lester holt dr oz oh my gosh she is a
rising star and today guess what rossi
we get to join that illustrious list i'm
so honored please welcome seven-year-old
behind the seventh questions with emmy
emmy eaton emmy
hi
i'm so excited to be talking with you
guys today oh my goodness emmy you've
done over 40 interviews and you've got
such a natural talent
what is it about interviewing that you
like so much
i like that i get to talk to so many
people that are so amazing and i love
asking questions do you do research do
you pick your subjects what's your
process well i think of what they
um they do like if i were interviewing
an author i would think oh what book did
they write and i would ask about that
and if they like read a fantasy i would
say okay why did you want to write a
fantasy
i love that have you always been curious
your whole entire life yes i've been
very curious
that's why you're a good journalist emmy
is there a story that you would like for
everyone to hear today that you feel is
important
um there was this person he's uh he
lives in rexburg he uh made an igloo
they call it the skittle igloo they put
pans of ice and then they use food
coloring and they stuck it on the igloo
they're the outrides they put lights in
so it looks really cool at night and the
dad's a doctor so every every day after
delivering a baby he would get back to
working on the igloo
okay emmy i just wish you the very best
and i want you to go out there and keep
asking the important questions showing
the fun things that are happening in
life and most importantly would you come
back and visit us yeah i'm good i'm so
glad we need more emmy the world needs
more emmy thank you so much for coming
today keep up the great work emmy thank
you
too
i just can't she's so cute and wonderful
don't go anywhere we've got more season
two secrets coming up that's right
[Music]
recipes
we're back to bring you more
[Music]
the new season of drew premieres
september 13th
welcome back that is the end of today's
trip down memory lane
but fret not in less than a week it's
the season two premiere of the drew
barrymore show and it is going to be
huge we've got mega celebrity guests
over-the-top segments i mean no one
would think i would do that the druziest
newsiest stories and
you've got a chance to win some serious
cash in a game we call six feet from six
thousand but that's not all
buckle up for something we're calling
bestie hour
and that means my bestie is coming back
yes it's an hour of me and cameron diaz
and we have a whole bunch of surprises
for a bunch of besties out there
you don't want to miss it because then
what would you talk about with your
bestie i mean come on tune in september
13th and until then
[Music]
you